your fear or your stress or your anxiety
or your worry it's all kind of in the
same continuum it accesses this body's
physiological response that negates the
ability for my brain to think clearly so
i'm cognitively dissociated
this is the curse of being human this is
a curse of every day waking up and
trying to battle this
welcome friend it's been a little while
since we had this planned
and i finally got you here well it takes
a while you're a busy man
busy schedule so i get it as are you
what
are you an expert in
ah that's a great question
um expert's kind of a loaded word let's
say um
let's say well-versed i'm well-versed in
uh brain physiology
neuroscience evolutionary psychology
psychology
uh the stress response anxiety the whole
continuum of the seven diagnosable
anxiety disorders
and i think just an overall
understanding
of how the brain operates
that's kind of some level of knowledge
that i possess
what links all of those together what's
the common thread between all of that
evolution it's really quite fascinating
to me
um we're kind of work we kind of stage a
battle in our own heads
uh for most of our life um
derived from two things really in
particular
one your central nervous system and two
your primordial midbrain autonomic
nervous system
and this is fascinating to me as we
evolved as humans and what separates you
and i
from primates is this prefrontal cortex
in frontal cortex
in this area of our brain which is our
forehead is our executive functioning
our left brain
analytical thinking but it's also access
to our personality and our character
it allows us to be patient be good
listeners be empathetic
and then you have another structure in
the brain called the reptilian side of
the brain or the midbrain
which is the autonomic nervous system
and that piece
is designed for primordial survival
so that fight or flight mechanism
is so much more evolved because it's
40 million years of neuronal circuitry
40 million years
that's hard to fathom how much learning
goes on in 40 million years of the
structure of the brain it's
really quite phenomenal the frontal
cortex and the prefrontal cortex and our
character and our personality and our
ability to logically think through and
decision make and executive functioning
is four million years involved so chris
we as a human being
are constantly perpetually challenged
with a 36 million year head start
to this primordial side of our brain
that's really really nefarious in its
ability to create insecurity
and expectation and fear and doubt and
self-loathing and
it's just bizarre but that's what it
means to be a human
so yeah that's what kind of links what
we do is the neuronal circuitry of the
brain
and how important is it
it it creates everything that we do
everything we do we think that we
control
ourselves we think that we're in control
we're not in control
not at all your brain your central
nervous system and your autonomic
nervous system
are light years ahead of you light years
think about craving think about the idea
of craving
think about the battles you have in your
head whether it's around a carb or a
sugar
or an alcohol or marijuana it doesn't
matter
think about if you can if you have
enough self-awareness the last time you
succumbed to craving
and think about when the craving started
it wasn't hasty it wasn't hey this
is gonna happen on impulse that craving
started a couple days before you
actually
gave up and said i'm i'm in right
who's in control you're not
your brain knows what it wants when you
walk into a restaurant and you crave
a hamburger it's not because the
hamburger looks good on the menu
it's your brain knows you need protein
at that point you're deficient and it
knows hey
hamburger is the best way for protein if
you're in psychic pain and you're having
a tough day
your brain knows that alcohol is really
predictable and fast acting to get me
out of psychic pain i can deal with my
problems tomorrow
that's the challenge so i look at this
and i think of
people who think they're in control and
little do they know
ignorance is bliss i guess but they have
no idea
the advanced circuitry of your brain is
it a constant battle
between you and all the brain constant
battle
i'll give you a good example your
central nervous
system and this area of the brain
is focused on survival now when you
think of maslow's hierarchy of needs and
you think of the need and sense of
belonging and intimacy
and food and water and higher
consciousness all that is great
but it really is inconsequential if
you're not alive
okay so survival supersedes everything
that's your central nervous system's
challenge your central nervous system
has all five senses in your intuition
your intuition is probably more powerful
than your other five senses you know
inherently and intuitively when you're
at risk
okay maybe part of its socialization but
when you're walking home when it's a
dark
night and there's a couple people or
shadows in the distance and you're like
uh
i don't feel comfortable that's your
central nervous system saying hey this
doesn't feel right
it activates the only tool it has in the
shed so if you look at the central
nervous system as batman
the autonomic nervous system is robin it
says hey amygdala
you need to go do what you do and
mobilize for a threat because
something's going to happen here that i
don't like
that's kind of how it all works so i
think about something simple and
something behavioral
say you were at a party and you got
humiliated for whatever reason
you know you had a interpersonal
conflict that got loud and gregarious
and
you felt like you'd been belittled or
whatever your central nervous system
doesn't really appreciate shame okay
shame is
guilt's external shame is harder to deal
with because it's internal you're
it's your own battle so your central
nervous system is like
i don't really like that chris that
wasn't fun so there's a party coming up
next saturday
what happens on thursday you start
coming up with reasons
why you can't go to that party it's not
because you don't want to go to that
party
but your central nervous system's memory
bank says hey
i remember when we did that and the
person that emasculated me is going to
be at that party
i don't think we should go see this is
how the brain the central nervous system
and the autonomic nervous system
and the autonomic nervous system with
fear stress anxiety depression and worry
and the continuum of our behavior is
challenged
by all of the circuitry and yet we think
we're in control of any of this stuff
which we're not
but your brain has an incredibly memory
center
and it remembers every time that you've
failed physically emotionally
spiritually psychologically
it remembers every time of public
shaming it remembers every time that you
were hurt
and it tries to avoid these things out
of primordial need for survival
so what do you think how's that for a
way to kick off a podcast there's a lot
of challenges being human
it's difficult i'm surprised that anyone
makes it through alive
well actually alive
but but not acting to their core and
they're in the honor of who they want to
be
well life the only thing that we can
guarantee is that none of us are going
to make it out alive
unless david sinclair manages to do his
unlimited immortal
nmn infusion [ __ ] before we before
we hit the end of the century yeah man i
mean
i i've been fascinated by this for a
long time the fact that
we have a little bit of metacognition
right we can think about thinking we can
observe
the cravings as they arise inside of us
and
determinism aside we are able to act
or not act on those impulses at least as
our system sees fit
to do so so the fact that we get a
little bit of a glimpse
as these things go past us is
a source of a lot of suffering for
people right the fact that
i could have done differently i should
have done differently
if everything ran purely automatically
you wouldn't really have much of a place
for regrets because you didn't
make the choice now again argument's
about free will aside that's for a
different podcast
but when you're waiting
to watch and see what next occurs in
your mind you don't choose where it
comes from but you can choose how you
respond to it or at least it feels like
you can
and that does give you a conflict you
can
alright so you bring up a really
interesting point and it's the
physiology of resource allocation
okay let's talk through evolutionary
psychology here
is stress happens well first and
foremost to the thought process
according to the months we have a
thousand thoughts an hour that's a lot
of those thousand thoughts maybe 990 are
externally derived
so that's kind of sucks so it's coming
from the external
world these thoughts they're not really
generated internally if you're
meditating maybe but
for the most part they're external so
we're having to react to our environment
all the time
but a stress happens a stress response
happens
anything whether it's perceived or
you're thinking about a date or
you're thinking about a dental
appointment it doesn't matter what it is
what what is going on
so the central nervous system is one
that's kind of governing you and kind of
knows your schedule and your executive
functioning and knows what's happening
what's not and also has the memory of
shame guilt and
all your failures isn't that amazing if
you
if you interrogated your essential
nurses like wow i had a lot more
failures than i remember
it holds a lot of cards man i'm telling
you so
the central nervous system perceives a
threat real or perceived it doesn't
matter
something happens physiologically and
this is important for people to
understand
the amygdala is an almond-shaped piece
of the midbrain and the amygdala is kind
of the flight deck
of the fight-or-flight response and it's
an almond-shaped piece in your midbrain
that pings the hpa axis which is the
hypothalamic pituitary adrenal cortex
this axis drives the adrenal cortex to
secrete adrenaline
so the central nervous system brain your
executive thinking
has a fear that fear triggers the
amygdala
to mobilize you for a threat and this is
some important stuff here
number one when this happens there's no
neuronal firings to the frontal cortex
your brain doesn't know you're even
preparing to mobilize for a threat
because your primordial midbrain saying
hey
we've been asked by the central nervous
system to go into high alert we need to
mobilize
something's happening not sure what it
is yet but let's go
so all of your resources go to your
visceral organs
to prepare to fight the heart rate
the the breath the musculature your old
factory
your peripheral vision and here's what's
happening
it's called resource allocation if all
my resources
in the form of oxygen-rich red blood are
now leaving the frontal
cortex of my brain to go to the body and
the midbrain to solve these problems
i am no longer cognitively associated
and connected with my being
so that's what's happening you
and i can be responsive to a stressful
stimulation
and not reactionary in the event that we
are in this place of autonomic
nervousness and balance
most people aren't so we're easily
triggered and when we're triggered we
lose the concept of our personality and
our character and we go into a
behavioral pattern that's in fight or
flight and survival
and we learn these patterns we're
socialized to these patterns
so what happens is your fear or your
stress or your anxiety or your worry
it's all kind of in the same
continuum it accesses this body's
physiological response that negates the
ability for my brain to think clearly
so i'm cognitively dissociated
this is the curse of being human this is
the curse of
day waking up and trying to battle this
so when you think of
mindfulness or you think of meditation
or you think of
things that will help you get to a place
of higher consciousness
that path in and of itself is a
different conversation but in reality
all you're trying to do is allocate
proper resources in the form of oxygen
rich red blood cells to the frontal
cortex
so if i'm in a state of well-being and
i'm balanced and i feel good
you can come at me with stress okay but
i will be able to interpret it
and i'll be able to measure it and
respond to it
on my terms using both my primordial
midbrain
and my frontal cortex what happens in
most human behavioral modification
issues is that the blood flow and
resource allocation
leaves the frontal cortex entirely and
you're left in this fight-or-flight
response
and you can you've seen this your whole
life i don't know how old you are but
you've had many many experiences across
your life
and you've had many experiences where
you saw people handle stressful
situations well and not handle them well
and we find ourselves easily judging
these people like wow that person's a
loser
or wow they're weak or wow that dude was
crying
no you can't judge them
for doing what they're set up to do the
neuronal circuitry has them protecting
themselves and staying alive
there's no judgment they're simply
surviving
and they don't have access to their
person and their character and their
well-being
because there's no blood flow there so
that's the biggest challenge
and so there is semblances of control
and being able to be responsive to
stress as opposed to reactionary
and the path you take to higher
consciousness is the path
to enlightenment the physiological
challenge there is simply oxygenating
the frontal cortex so when you meditate
what are you doing you're trying to
synchronize and slow down your
respiration rate to one breath every 10
seconds
10 breaths or 6 breaths a minute
is the ultimate diaphragmatic breathing
for a human being and oxygen-rich red
blood cells is the path to healing
physically mentally spiritually and
emotionally that's the challenge
so when we look at hey mindfulness seems
ethereal
mindfulness seems like an attainable
aspirational goal that i can't achieve
mindful
no it's not and i don't care what path
you take
you can take meditation you can take
yoga you can take tai chi you can take
wim hof's breathing it doesn't matter
the key
is to slow down cortisol in your monkey
mind and oxygenate the enterprise the
enterprise being
your body and your mind because when
your body and your mind are oxygenated
you're in a place of well-being that's
the key
i have been in situations where my
recovery and my balance between my
autonomic
nervous system i don't think has changed
a massive amount
but my experience my conscious
experience of the situation has
let's say it's my industry running club
nights
between the ages of 23 and 28
i think if anything i got poorer
recovery
i think i was more chronically in sleep
debt
uh training was the same diet was the
same but
my experience my conscious experience of
the situation had changed and improved
so how would that fit into the model
that you've just given me there
because that's complete complete left
turn and uh
this is awesome i love i love these
types of conversations because you have
no idea an expectation where it's going
to go so what you're speaking of is
completely different
and what you're speaking to is a
different part of the human experience
you're speaking to this network of
experience and this wisdom
and this growth through a network of
experiences what the what the hell does
that mean
we have something called a reticular
activated system and it's the body's
filtration system it's the most
sophisticated filter
in the history of this planet your
reticular activation system
governs all stimulation into your brain
all five senses in your intuition
think about the job that has that's a
big responsibility think about how much
comes into your visual cortex on a daily
basis everything
you couldn't absorb everything your
brain would be like ah
i'm done so reticular activating system
is the key
and is the filter the reticular
activation system has two primary
functions and it's exceptionally good at
number one
pattern recognition number two finding
shortcuts
so you're in this space from 23 to 28
and you're living this life there
your circadian rhythm is compromised
your stress level is high
your nutrition is probably poor your
sleep's messed up your cortisol is high
you're pushing the limits of what it
means to be a human
and you're young and you your sense of
mortality doesn't exist yet so
you can do this i'm made of rubber and
magic between the ages of 23 and 28 gym
i was fine
it's amazing isn't it you're very
malleable and it's it is it's amazing
i'm 52 so i have a three-day hangover
now i i just don't like it and i don't
tolerate it
anyway so the reticular activation
system from 23 to 28
is taking all these disparate
experiences and it's networking
them and so you're taking pieces from
this night
and you're saying hey i saw that before
and this is how this works
that's how we build this ability to
gain wisdom and experience on top of
everything
that we do it's a different aspect of
the of the
evolutionary psychology of the challenge
between the autonomic nervous system and
the primordial midbrain
and the central nervous system in your
prefrontal cortex different aspect
but it's a fascinating aspect because we
have to be able to be malleable and we
have to be able to be adaptive to our
environment
and life comes at us right there's 7.6
billion people on this planet
7.6 billion think about the energy
involved in just that but then you add
in
everybody's inner wisdom or what i like
to call the itty bitty shitty committee
it's not so wise it's a committee that
tells you you suck
you're insecure you're a loser they're
not going to understand you people
aren't going to like you at this party
you know that committee that kind of
talks to us every day since we're since
we're little
and we don't really tell people about it
so in essence chris we have 7.6 billion
people
plus 7.6 itty-bitty shitty committees
we got 15 billion plus enterprises on
this planet occupying energy right and
entropy
and it's incredibly fascinating but
there are ways for us to create
a semblance of patterns we can be
resilient and we can be adaptive to any
it
appears to me anything on earth anything
from war to space travel to deep sea
travel anything that humans sets their
mind to
they can adapt to it it's because of the
capability of the reticulated
system to understand patterns understand
how to find shortcuts and then build
upon each experience so from 23 to 28
you were pushing the limits
physiologically of your body but you
were learning
every day and each experience was
stacking on the prior experience
how does someone we're talking about
going back to the autonomic nervous
system and that balance and getting that
right
i'm not meditating when i'm
out on the front door of a nightclub or
in a stressful situation
so there must be some sort of carryover
my recovery that i have done prior to
the event
must somehow permit me to have a bigger
window of tolerance of stress within the
event when it occurs
is that the way that it works yes yes so
it's it's a reserve
okay i look at this i look at it as a
seesaw right
seesaw's never really balanced one's up
ones down
most people live with the sympathetic
nervous system which is the stress
response
in full depressed accelerator foot's on
the gas man
that's most people living like that a
lot of people aren't in balance most
people aren't in balance
but it's a continuum so the more you do
nutritionally the more you do sleep-wise
the more you do kind of meditative wise
the healthier you build that reserve so
that you have the resilience to deal
with stressful situations so
um just intuitively without you even
understanding what you're even
observing you're observing exactly that
your observations and what you do and
how you do it you're finding
this evolution but you obviously are on
a quest for balancing the autonomic
nervous system you may not even have
been aware that you were doing that
so yeah that's what that's what's
happening what do you think more
people should know about stress that
they don't
that it's necessary it's a necessary
piece of the puzzle
right certainly the survival piece is
the intuition
is but i think there's a lot of
burned wasted calories in stress fear
and worry
it's really quite unfortunate now
something interesting for your listeners
um your brain and my brain are different
than a female's brain
we know this intuitively we know this
through the lack of empathy and
and the complexity of a woman's thought
process versus man's
but in reality it's physiologically
different the corpus callosum the bridge
between the laterality of your left and
right brain
is bigger in a woman's brain than a
man's
so if we say hey
i'm not worried about that i'm not being
dismissive or callous to my wife
i'm incapable of worrying about it so if
you say hey
what's our 14 year old daughter gonna
wear a picture day three weeks from now
i am incapable of worrying about that so
i'm not waking up at three in the
morning and perseverating over that for
90 minutes
okay second thing that's important to
note difference between a male and
female brain
is that with the corpus callosum being
bigger and the laterality being greater
the packets of information from the left
and the right brain in your analytical
and your creative brain a female is
capable of multitasking
where a man isn't so there you go
so personally i think about that say wow
i feel really blessed to be a man
because i don't like to worry and i
can't
i can't multitask either so here you go
so that's the reality we live in forget
the complexity of a woman
of a woman's brain and their ability to
so
men are more focused and left brain and
solution oriented
women are more empathetic and
emotionally connected
and so there's a dissonance it almost
doesn't make sense that a man and a
woman should be together because like
you know this it doesn't make any sense
we don't communicate in the same manner
and so i learned years ago
my wife didn't want the answer because
when i gave it to her just created six
more layers of problems
she just wanted to hear me she just
wanted me to listen
because they're not coming to you with a
solution
they just want to be heard fascinating
so two stories recently that i've heard
from um
adam lane smith who was a
psychotherapist specializing in trauma
and he was talking about the fact that
men
are treated for depression the way that
women want to be treated for depression
all that you need to give a man
according to him in order to get most of
them
out of depression is a purpose and the
ability to
complete that purpose but when they go
in
a lot of the time therapy is geared
around men being heard
being felt appreciated but that's not
what they want they want a problem and
they want to fix it
in fact there were people during world
war
ii in london who were in insane asylums
catatonic completely catatonic laid in
bed hadn't been out of bed for years
and as soon as the bombs started to drop
they got up
they went outside and they started
shoveling they drove ambulances they did
all of these jobs
because they had a purpose and the
ability to complete it another thing
second thing that i learned one of my
favorite facts from this year from david
buss one of the founders of evolutionary
psychology that was recently on the show
talking about the male over perception
bias and the female under perception
bias of attraction
so men are hardwired to over-perceive
the level of attraction that a female is
giving to them
they like any like a scrap like a scrap
precisely well yeah they they're there
to look at something and say well
her gaze lingered at me for 0.3
milliseconds longer than it usually does
it's like maybe you had sauce on your
shirt maybe she was thinking god it's
that creepy gym guy again
like whatever it might be
[Laughter]
but men are wired to
view every potential sexual opportunity
as one
and conversely women do the opposite
and when they do self-reporting speed
dating he's done it with tons and tons
of different studies
women consistently report far less
attraction
from them to the man than the man
reports and the man reports far more
attraction from the women to the man
than the female reports
but this tells us it explains so much
around why men and women
struggle to get along because they don't
have
the same makeups sexually men want more
sexual variety
and they're happy to have sex more soon
than a woman is
women want more consistency with sex and
it takes longer for them to do it
61 of the time men say that i love you
first and they report feeling it
at 90 days around about 90 to 91 days
after first meeting someone all of these
things
why are there these asymmetries because
we are not the same because we were not
built
to be the same and yeah it's an absolute
given the fact that it's about
50 50 split on the planet between men
and women
you know of all of the different wars
between
countries and and geographies and areas
and belief structures
the fact that 50 and 50 of the world
aren't just tearing each other apart
because we're quite different to each
other is i think we should be
we should be proud of that there's a
simple way to explain the sexual
difference and that is
a man needs to have sex to feel intimate
and a woman needs to feel intimate to
have sex
it's a nice little way to look at him
like okay it is it's
it's fascinating isn't it another one uh
that rob henderson uses he says
men need an excuse not to have sex with
a woman women need an excuse to have sex
with a man
yes and that's a bummer yeah well it
depends
it depends which angle you're coming at
it from okay so stress autonomic nervous
balance we've got there
talk to me about given the fact that
this is your special special area at the
moment and you've been in it for quite a
while
have your has your research been showing
increasing ramping up levels of
stress just how bad is it is it as bad
as people make out are people just being
sort of
[ __ ] at the moment or are we getting
bombarded with dopamine from
devices and such like have you been able
to actually see any of these changes
it's worse it's worse than people
surmise
the stress level anxiety level fear
level uncertainty level so prior to
covet covet kind of exponentially
changes everything
but prior to kovid we were already
living in the second great age of
anxiety the first great age of anxiety
was posed world war one
so your central nervous system as we've
already you know talked about
protects us it keeps us alive and it
needs
some semblance of of being grounded
it needs a pattern the reticular
activation system demands that we're
creatures a habit
okay after war one the world didn't seem
like
itself it was off kilter and that lack
of certainty
leaves this feeling us not grounded it
leads to anxiety anticipatory anxiety
so prior to covid we were in the second
great age of anxiety a lot of that has
to do with a poor food supply
when your food is more acidic and more
focused on sugar
you're not getting the balanced
nutrients you need in the inhibitory
neurotransmitter
side of the equation we have a lot of
excitatory neurotransmitters and a lot
of neurotoxins in our food
so for say the last 40 years our food
balance has
lost its way and we're far more acidic
that's not good for anxiety okay it's
not good for depression
that that it's not good for sleep our
sleep
has been compromised whether it's our
job choice or whatever and then you have
this proliferation
of technology and the push
of blue light to the brain constantly
stimulating us okay
so that's the physiological piece the
blue light stimulates it says hey it's
go time let's get some adrenaline
and then you have all the research
showing that this social media craze
creates an addictive response of
dopamine much like cocaine
so when a child puts out something on
instagram
and starts seeing who likes it or shares
or whatever that elicits a dopamine
response so we're so between technology
between the lack of kind of the nuclear
and extended family
being around each other the food supply
and then just kind of mass media so
follow the money that's really the way
life works right
follow the economics i don't believe
that the media is nefarious and thinking
malicious thoughts but what they do know
is that they need ratings they need
ratings that they can make their money
and stay profitable and pay their bills
and their overhead and pay their
salaries okay great
so what do they learn they learn this
they bring in some neuroscientists and
they say hey
i can elicit a fear response in a
nanosecond
it takes me minutes to create this
intellectual challenge and this story of
good and
and releasing endorphins and oxytocin so
we're gonna go fear-mongering
everything's fear-mongering everything
in the mass media
is to elicit a fear response and that
fear response triggers the amygdala the
amygdala to the hba axis
the autonomic nervous system all your
blood flow goes from your brain and
you're getting that fear pattern
i tell people in a lecture i was like
when's the last time you turned off the
news and you had a feeling of
inner peace and calm and serenity
uh like never never so between the food
the media this disconnect of humanity
i've got three girls 19 17 and 14 when
they have interpersonal conflict i hear
about it
and my idea is hey go over to their
house and talk to them or pick up the
phone
no everything's done through text
there's a layer
it's really strange so there's a there's
a ton going on
so on one hand you'd say stress is at
the highest levels
ever in the history of the human
experience
that's a sad indictment but that's
reality on the other hand
look at the resilience and ability for
adaptive behavior
that's really quite exceptional and what
i have noticed
personally is the adaptive behavior of
my children
19 17 and 14. they have adapted to covet
a hell of a lot better than i have at 52
years old and why is that
it's not a miracle it's not the
demographic it's simply
the network of experiences that i have
52 years and 365 days a year
has a big big big group
of ideas and dogma and conventional
thinking and what should be
you're more interested and more
entrenched and they have 1917 14 year
old
thinking so it's been really quite
fascinating to look at all this but
i'll give your audience one example of
how covet's going to affect
us moving forward number one you need
pattern recognition because if you don't
it exhausts your brain trying to figure
out what the hell this is
this is the idea of a first impression
so i'm in boston in august of last year
2020
and it's i mean faneuil hall which is
literally like a tourist trap
and thousands of tourists from all over
and restaurants and
the harbors right there and the old you
know england style architecture it's a
beautiful place
it's august it's about 7 30 at night and
i'm in faneuil hall
and i looked left and looked right
there's not a single
soul out on the street
my brain can't process this it can't
it's literally having to burn extra
calories trying to figure out
what has happened here is this an
apocalypse did i miss something
so this is exhausting
so from march 2020 to today it has
exhausted us
emotionally spiritually psychologically
and physically because we've had to work
double and triple and quadruple hard
because our brain
can't nothing is normal it's just a
novel environment everything is a novel
environment
every day so it's just and there's a lot
of social anxiety there's a lot of
social um divisiveness there's a lot of
vaccine versus non-vaccine and is this
real or is this a hoax there's
so much drama going on what does that do
it
perpetuates this feeling of uncertainty
and uncertainty leads to anticipatory
anxiety and depression so if you
had a proclivity to be depressed the
covet accelerates and
and creates a more intense depression
your episodes are longer and the
intensity is greater same thing with
anxiety
so this whole continuum is managed by
the autonomic nervous system the
autonomic nervous system
in addition to fight or flight governs
human fear stress anxiety depression and
worry
it's a big piece of our behavioral
modification
so i think this i think the stress side
is is incredible
and i um i hope that we learn
i hope we're not in a rush to get back
to
a pace of life and a destruction of the
planet that's really not
tenable you may say hey this is a
universal intervention
where the universe says hey enough is
enough there's 7.6 billion of you you're
egregious you're wasteful and you're
ruining everything
because from from march 2020 to like
december 2020
the animal kingdom was thriving they
were seeing
schools of dolphins and whale pods
literally orca
type whales in areas of the [ __ ] in the
country in america they hadn't seen in
centuries
right so pollution's down air quality is
up
but as a human i hope people
stopped and said wow this doesn't unplug
this was an unplug for me to reflect
and kind of introspectively look at my
life and look what i thought was
important
and why did i go to bed every night
disappointed that i didn't achieve my
to-do list when i look at my to-do list
none of them are consequential to my
life
i hope that we don't rush to normalcy
when you look at normal and normal
wasn't working
the problem is a lot of people have only
had that to-do list to keep them going
through this period
you know a lot of people are driven by
the desire to do more to achieve more
meritocracy quantifiable metrics of
success
fears of insufficiency all of these
things combined to make the to-do list
completion
one of the few things that you derive
meaning from and if you remove
most sources of happiness as well that's
a great point
happiness and meaning are two different
pathways i learned this from
roy baumeister it's awesome and um
happiness is much more impulsive it's in
the here and now
meaning is future focused it's purpose
it's a future event or state that lends
structure to the moment
which is a really good definition for
purpose and um
they're not the same thing and i think
you know i have a
as yet unproven hypothesis that i think
a lot of people
are struggling to find happiness and
have done over the last
15 months and have tried to replace
happiness with meaning
and the meaning has been found by
set goal work toward goal complete goals
set next goal work toward goal complete
goal
um there hasn't been much opportunity
for impulsive happiness parties
you know you can't really flex your new
car on instagram if you're not allowed
out of the house
uh financial concerns so on and so forth
and i'm
i think people have perhaps used meaning
as
a replacement for it well i think um
there's another element there so we do a
lot of work with monks and we learn a
lot from the wisdom of monks
their path is different and probably
similar
happiness is external just like guilt's
external
joy is internal and the path to joy
maybe commensurate with a path to
meaning
but happiness is a futile attempt
and it it doesn't last because it is
external just like guilt's external
guilt is imposed upon societal norms
shame is
inside me so you're speaking
to the same path of lower consciousness
you're speaking to the primordial
midbrain occupying more of your
resources than your frontal cortex
your to-do list is rather
inconsequential to your life
and certainly doesn't derive happiness
ever you buy a nice fancy car
great how long is that the endorphins
last two weeks
three weeks happiness is a pursuit of
futility
and over expectation and
disappointment you want to drive towards
joy
you want to get an understanding
baseline fundamental of who you are as a
core human being
and what gives you joy right was it
having children is it having a spouse
and a partner
is it work is it purpose that's the path
to an enlightened life of wellness and
well-being
and this pursuit of happiness or to do's
or
this over pursuit of success based on
what monetary success that
that no it doesn't work that way and
we're speaking to the same
stuck this in this rut of this continuum
of fear stress anxiety depression and
worry
this is 40 million year evolved thinking
no we want access to here i want access
to my personality my
like the honor of my humanity and
my character what's important to me not
what i think other people
think is important to me it's all stress
modulated so you're this brain guy you
got all these insights into the brain
and stuff like that what
how are you deploying these in the
market what do you do for work
new calm baby so
20 plus years ago an exceptionally
gifted neuroscientist quantum physicist
naturopath dr g
blake holloway went on a quest literally
took him 20 years
that and of itself is incredible badge
of honor who spends 20 years trying to
figure something out
but his clinical practice in texas was
resolving ptsd comorbid with addiction
so traumatized people coming out of the
theater of war
or female sexual physical emotional
abuse victims
the ptsd side you said you just recently
had someone on with ptsd or talk about
ptsd
it's exceptionally powerful and
exceptionally gripping and it basically
takes your life if it doesn't take your
life through suicide it commandeers the
rest of your life
and you live a life of misery it's a
horrific
place of the seven diagnosable anxiety
disorders ptsd is on the furthest
extreme
it is the hardest life to live and so we
judge people for finding solace in drugs
and alcohol
but we don't understand the neuronal
network of of the brain
if i'm in psychic pain and i can never
get relief
and even in my dreamscape i'm having
memories associated with the trauma
i can never rest i can never my
shoulders can never drop
i can never have a moment of serenity
i'm gonna find an escape
my brain's smart it's gonna figure out
how to get into cocaine or
you know opiates or alcohol that's how
this all works right
so it this technology was designed
to resolve ptsd comorbid with addiction
that's the hardest profile of humanity
to solve
now when you asked dr holloway why'd you
do it what were you seeking
today conventional therapy includes
narcotic-based pharmaceuticals
to dull the pain not solve the issue
dull the pain
and then do cognitive behavioral therapy
on a brain that's not willing and able
and open
the brain of a traumatized victim is in
the constant state of hyper vigilance
they have lost trust in the universe and
they've lost trust in you
to protect you from the universe
this is gang buster fight or flight all
the time okay
this technology this platform this
neuroscience
platform technology was designed
expressly to balance the autonomic
nervous system
this is really important because people
don't understand what the autonomic
nervous system is
its value and kind of what it governs in
our in our life
the autonomic nervous system has two
sides the stress response which is
called the sympathetic nervous system
and the rest response which is called
the parasympathetic nervous system
but in that it also governs the
fight-or-flight response
and the continuum of mood disorders from
fear stress anxiety depression and worry
that's a big job the autonomic nervous
system has a big job
it's not given enough right liberty
privilege honor respect for us to take
care of it anymore
we're too eager to eat shitty food and
not sleep well and drink and party and
get on our tech all the time
we don't think about balance in fact
balance seems like it's weak
you know meditation yoga tai chi is for
weak people no it's not
it's actually the antithesis of weak
people it's actually the path to
healthy you want to live a good life so
this technology
was designed and derived to solve the
problem of the stress response because
if you don't solve the stress response
the body is not in a position to heal
i'm not even
open chris to begin the healing process
if i can't take my foot off the
accelerator
to be able to you want to get down to
the core of it
it's really to shut down cortisol in
your monkey mind shut down
the stress hormones because the cortisol
and the adrenaline
and the catecholamines are driving all
this mood disorder and all this poor
food choices and addiction and all this
stuff
it's all stress modulated when we're
stressed out and we
feel you can feel in your stomach right
there's too much acid in your stomach
when you're stressed out
it doesn't feel good how would you like
to live
the entirety of your life in that space
that's exhausting i wouldn't want that
i don't like it for one second when i
feel cortisol in my stomach or i lose my
appetite
or i'm feeling distracted or i'm here
with you present but something else is
distracting me i don't like that feeling
so new calm is the core platform
technology
developed by this neuroscientist and
here's what's fascinating to me
the brain is the most complex organ in
the history of this planet
okay the complexities cannot be
overstated and the complexities are
still not even known
but we do know a few things one the body
is a closed loop ecosystem with
trillions of cells
and the body in the brain is a
compensatory mechanism
with a complexity that's beyond our
comprehension what does that mean
for every action there's a reaction for
that reaction as a reaction for that
reaction as a reaction for that reaction
there's a reaction
okay so it's entropy so you think about
that and you say okay
how would you create a solution
to manage the autonomic nervous system
on a regular basis it
it demands a complex solution and that's
in
exactly what he invented in new column
the brain and the body communicate in
only two manners chemical messaging and
electrical messaging
and if you don't command control of both
mechanisms
you can't have a predictable outcome and
we look at this and we see what's out
there
today we see neurobiofeedback's been
around for almost 80 years
it's not predictable it's not
predictable to the individual and it's
not predictable across the population
we look at transcranial direct current
stimulation and different stimulation
devices that
stimulate a certain area of the brain
they're not predictable they're not
predictable
across the person they're not
predictable across the population
then you take the other approach that's
the electrical signaling you take the
chemical signal you talk about
supplementation
or transdermal creams or liposomal
sublingual
absorption whatever but they're not
driving to anything
and the body is not good at extracting a
high yield of nutrients from
supplementation
it's really good at taking nutrients
from food
it does a really poor job when you're
talking about a seven to nine percent
yield
of what you ingest in a supplement to me
it's like once you just throw the whole
thing down the toilet
seven to nine percent is not that good
is that the max
nine percent i believe is about the max
yeah so
and you can make a dose but it doesn't
matter because you have to go through
the whole metabolic process you have to
go through the liver you have to go
through the bloodstream it's across the
blood brain barrier there's a million of
inefficiencies in the body trying to
extract
and and something that's really quite
fascinating
what are we taking it for anyway why do
we even ingest food
what is it all about what's human
biology about
human biology is about cellular
communication it's all about
bioinformatics
cell to cell communication what are they
communicating they're communicating a
frequency
do they not need something a resource
from the actual supplement or the food
itself though
rather than it just being a signal is
there not a resource
in it itself the seven percent of the
nine percent which gets the use
the resource and what you're looking for
has a frequency
so if you're looking for vitamin a that
has a frequency vitamin b has a
frequency b12 has a frequency vitamin c
has a frequency vitamin d
has a frequency magnesium has a
frequency so
when you eat a food there's this whole
process of inefficiencies that goes
on so i chew the food i digested my
esophagus to my gum my gut
digests it then i process through my
liver and i metabolize that in my
bloodstream
and all it's doing is communicating a
frequency of that nutrient
human biology is resonance frequency and
vibration
it's fascinating to me so when you drink
orange juice you're not drinking it
because there's a little vitamin c
pellet that your cells say hey grab that
vitamin c pellet and let's wrestle to
the ground no there's a frequency and
that frequency resonates so the cell
gets the frequencies okay that's vitamin
c and it's like a
tuning fork it resonates at that
frequency that's biology
so when you look at the body and what
we're trying to do we're trying to
impose our will through supplementation
you can't impose your will on the human
brain good luck
it's not going to work so when you take
a step back
and you understand the complexity of the
brain you have electrical signaling and
chemical signaling
dr holloway understood that to create a
predictable outcome
i have to commandeer both channels so
new call
is a systematic approach it is a
systematic
complex solution to a complex problem
and newcomb itself is one product and
it's designed
to literally slow down your brainwave
function
the opposite of what caffeine does
caffeine increases your brainwave
frequency and lets you think faster and
activate faster
newcomb is designed to slow down your
brainwave function
and to oscillate your brain in alpha and
theta
alpha being synonymous with relaxation
rest and creativity
theta being synonymous with healing
cellular restoration and recovery
that's what he's doing so new calm is a
gift
to humanity it's a gift to our
contemporary
lifestyle where we're not in control of
ourselves anymore
and we're not thinking that
balance and parasympathetic dominance
and recovery and rest
is really that important we seem to
override that a lot
if you look today at the global
marketplace
the sleep industry alone is a 585
billion dollar industry 585 billion
dollars
we don't know that much about sleep
academically the science of sleep is 29
years old
who who thought that was a good idea
sleep
is paramount to life
you don't sleep you die you don't sleep
well
you don't perform well but what's the
catalyst to create poor sleep
stress hello it's cause and effect
so to us we look at high stress poor
sleep high stress poor sleep high stress
poor sleep and we say hey
we have a solution that's clinically
proven and patented
to take care of that how would you like
to live in a world where you have
great sleep good stress management great
sleep good stress management
so where we sit
in america here the companies in
delaware we've built
a platform of technologies designed
to allow you to change your state on
demand with no side effects by managing
the human brainwave function that sounds
really complex and start tracking
and it is the complexity is incredible
the science is
absolutely incredible you could study
this science
for decades and not get bored because
it's constantly evolving because we're
learning more and learning more and
learning more like wow
that's really cool let's do this but
let's take a step back
the human brain and the body in your
behavior
and the outcome are all derived from
this scale of a 41 hertz
to 0.5 hertz continuum let's start at
the lowest
0.5 hertz when your brain wave is in a
slow waveform of 0.5 hertz
you are in dreamless coma like
deep sleep okay we've all witnessed it
where you literally can't wake somebody
up they're literally in
delta 0.5 hertz when you go up from
delta and you increase the frequency
seven hertz to four hertz is theta t h e
t
a theta is really really important
because it is the healing zone and is
the only time
when your brain wave function is in
theta that your cells clean their toxins
and do their cellular maintenance
and your mitochondria is restored that's
the healing zone
it's also commensurate with the second
stage of sleep
so rem second stage of sleep theta
brainwave function
then you go up to alpha 12 hertz to
eight hertz when your brain wave
function is an alpha
you're in the creative zone you're
relaxed but you're also in the zone
interestingly enough when they did eegs
or they do cross-sections of brains
of fighter pilots in a dogfight you
think wow they must be [ __ ] stressed
out
they're not their brain waves at 12
hertz they are in the zone
they are focused just like anybody who's
ever been in the zone we've all been in
the zone before we're like wow
i'm in the zone your brain weighs at 12
hertz that's alpha
alpha's also synonymous with
transcendental meditation
then you go up into beta beta has the
longest range from 13 hertz all the way
up to 38 hertz
13 to 15 hertz is low level kind of
adult functioning
you're awake and alert 15 to 20 hurts is
focused
distraction free i'm focused and i'm
crushing it
20 to 25 is stress 25 to 30 is high
stress and 30
to 38 is you're out of your freaking
mind stressed out of your marble
seriously you're not breathing well your
heart's palpitating
you're completely cognitive dissociated
you are in maximum fight or flight
okay then you go above that this is
really fascinating 39 to 41 hertz is a
gamma brainwave function
39 to 41 hertz is commensurate with
higher consciousness
and mistake free high intense focus
it's kind of it's kind of confusing
you're like wow that's
pretty wild so here's what dr holloway
invented
he invented a mathematical software
model using algorithms math and physics
to use your ears so auditory motor
cortex
as a way to deliver a signal to the
brain to pace your brain in any outcome
we want
we've created a platform of clinically
proven patented physics
where you listen to our tracks and you
can either derive 41 hertz
mistake free awesome focus intensity
called ignite warrior brain
or you can do new calm which is alpha
and theta
recovery cellular restoration or you can
do focus at 15 to 20 hertz
or you can do sleep at 0.5 hertz so yeah
we've been pretty busy here
working for about 20 years literally 20
years and 28 million dollars
to get to this place we've built the
only pathway
to literally elicit a state change so
you as a human being chris any day you
can get up
you say hey i didn't sleep that well
last night and i know that new calm
provides me
two hours of restorative sleep for every
20 minutes so i'm gonna do a new calm
right now and i'm gonna catch up on the
sleep debt that i incurred last night
because i know the human body can't make
up for sleep debt
but biochemistry and physics can so i
knew calm i get up from 45 minutes of
nuke home
and i feel like i slept great even
though i know i didn't i feel like i did
great you know why for that 45 minutes
we levitated your brainwave function in
theta
theta is synonymous with healing and
when you are in
theta synonymous being a monk you're
synchronizing your heart and your lungs
and you're breathing at the respiration
rate of one breath every 10 seconds
so that's kind of how all that works dr
holloway had the understanding
and the kind of the mystified brilliance
to say hey
i don't need to exercise to increase my
brainwave frequency
i don't need caffeine to increase my
brainwave frequency i don't need yoga
and tai chi to slower
to lower my brainwave frequency i'm
going to use physics
to manipulate the brainwave frequency
so that you can have whatever state you
want
that's incredible that's what we do so
newcomb is our flagship product it's
been around for 11 years
we've sold almost 25 million dollars in
newcomb it used to be a complex four
component class three medical devices
sold for six thousand dollars
well if your goal as a company is to
change the world and liberate humans
from stress
six thousand dollar price tag is not
really going to get you to the finish
line
so four and a half years ago we invested
a ton of money and time and effort and
resources
to say hey there must be a way for us to
simplify
and to get away from this and build a
consumer product so october 14th 2020
and that's probably one of the reasons
we're on this
podcast because when we were selling the
six thousand dollar
clinical medical device we weren't doing
a lot of podcasts because it's kind of
like yeah and you can get there for
shake shack and box no that's not gonna
fly
we launched a subscription model what we
did and what we accomplished in four and
a half years
with dr holloway who's just an
exceptionally gifted scientist
we were able to successfully move from a
classroom medical device to four
components to an easier to use three
component system
that's actually better who does that
what do you mean you're no longer a
regulated class medical device
you're simpler and you're better and in
addition we lowered the price 99.15
percent
you can get new calm now which a year
ago cost you six thousand dollars you
can get it now for
every day with the 39.99 of changing the
world i've got 7.6 billion people to
liberate from stress
just with new call it's a lot of work i
feel great about it someone says wow
that's a commercial in itself
you have all this weight of the world on
your shoulders and you're completely not
stressed i said what's there to be
stressed about
let's do it let's go so that's what we
do
so i at 52 years old running a global
neuroscience company with seven
industries across six continents we work
with the military and the va and
professional athletes and we work with
the gamut of humanity why is that
because here's what we know everybody
suffers the same consequence of being
human
i don't give a [ __ ] if you're a
celebrity you have stress and your
stress response
is exactly identical to my stress
response the amygdala the hpa axis
the blood flow all of it's the same we
are the same
7.6 billion people live with the curse
of stress and the stress response so we
have a solution
that's the only patented solution in the
world clinically proven
just by virtue of saying that no one
else can make these claims right
that solves the problem with no drugs
and no effort you literally just get in
your bed
you put a disc on your wrist a headphone
on an eye mask
and within a few four or five minutes
your brain weighs in theta
you bake there for 30 40 minutes and
when you're done you just kind of
pop up like hey i'm ready to go let's go
take on the day
that's new calm that's what we've done
so at 52 chris
i've got the immune health of a 37 year
old i've got the schedule of a carny
except i don't have small hands and
smell like cabbage
i travel like a freak i have a lot of
reasons to be a stressed out individual
and i'm not stressed at all i drink a
ton of water
and a new comb every day that's been my
key to longevity focus high performance
i was on the phone with a ceo about a
month ago and he interrupted me halfway
through a monologue he says mr paul i
just want to say one thing
you're like a super species you're a
freak i said i know
i said isn't it great i said i have a
basket of goods in the form of physics
and neuroscience where i can dictate
what state i want to be in
if i want to jack my brain up and go do
a run or go
work out or do whatever i want i can
just put ignite on
if i want to be focused and look at
legal paperwork i'll put focus on if i
want to sleep i'll put on a delta track
i manage my life through physics
understanding how to manage my brain
wave
boom what do you think of that mr chris
talk me through the
clinical studies what did you learn from
that what was found out
ah that's a great question um we were
always on a mission to manage stress you
have to stay in some sandbox right
we can we can make a lot of claims
because stress is the catalyst to
everything bad in our life
but we focus on stress and here's what
we learned it's really hard to manage
stress
and to quantifiably measure stress so we
started working with some of the best
scientists in the world
from harvard and nasa literally the best
mathematicians and
statistical biophysicists and what we
did was we learned that back then
heart rate variability was kind of a
burgeoning side in the medical equation
and has become the gold standard in
medical not in consumer
i wear an aura ring and woke banner and
stuff it's
it's their compromise and convenience
for medical grade
sensitivity accuracy they're not
accurate to hrv but you get an idea of
what it means
what is it our variability is looking at
the autonomic nervous system there's
something called the sympathovagal
balance
so it's a ratio of the sympathetic
nervous system over the parasympathetic
nervous system
and you can see when someone's four to
one eight to one ten to one
they're too stressed and there's not
enough rest so what we did is we had a
single lead ecg device and we measured
new calm so five minutes before during
new calm and five minutes after
and we studied the chicago blackhawks
stanley cup champions in 2013 to 2015
so some of the world's top athletes and
we studied stage four cancer
and they would have a single edcg device
they'd attach it to their chest
it would capture 250 data points a
second 15 000 a minute
and all that data five minutes before
during new column five minutes after
we'd get all that data we'd pass it over
to harvard medical school they would do
all the analysis
through this multi-scale entropy
mathematical model and spit out
the most sensitive accurate measurements
of your hrv and what we learned
was it didn't matter who you were it
didn't matter if you were a 31 year old
veteran
defenseman for the chicago black hawks
it didn't matter if you had stage four
metastatic brain cancer
new calm simply put the brakes on the
stress response within five minutes
and raise the parasympathetic to an
equal ratio or greater
so what we see any time you do new call
is that we will immediately put the
brakes on your stress response
and raise the rest and digest response
your body
and my body and everybody listening to
this podcast body
wants to be in balance it's your monkey
mind and cortisol
and your worries and your thoughts to
keep your body out of balance your body
knows how to heal
your body's had millions of years of
training it knows what to do
but your mind overrides it mostly
through the stress hormone cortisol
new calm says i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't care if you have cancer i don't
care for professional athlete i don't
care if you're a singer or a pilot
i don't care if you're two years old i
don't care if you're 100. i'm going to
take you to this place that i know
is commensurate with healing and i'm
going to allow you to spend time in that
coveted place and give you the
restoration your body needs and the more
you use this product
the more cumulative benefit because it
eventually is going to balance your
autonomic nervous system
and you're going to live in your
lifestyle working clubs at night
thinking like a monk living like a
capitalist
because you're going to be in a healthy
place where you have that resource
allocation
where you have enough oxygen-rich red
blood cells to your brain at all times
where you're not able to be sabotaged by
the primordial midbrain
eleven and a half years of using this
chris i am not prone to sabotage you're
not gonna get me
stressed and it doesn't matter it
doesn't mean i don't see it
feel it i manage people for a living
there's always stress to be had
you're never gonna find me sabotaged by
it because i've had such
use and such autonomic nervousness and
balance i have so many reserves i could
probably go two or three months without
new calm and still be in a place of
resilience and it's not because i'm
great
and it's not because i give myself the
gift of meditation or yoga tai chi i
don't do any of that
i don't take the time and that's not
important to me i use this as a tool
to replace anything in that continuum
that i know is necessary for good health
and really to be honest with you the
health aspect is less important to me
is the performance aspect i want to
perform from 5am to midnight
every single day so i'm available to my
team and my family
and i live the best proper life and i'm
honorable and integris to myself
and on the mission we're on five hours
of sleep a night on average
yeah i got the stupid aura ring so yes i
can tell you exactly
there's no cheating the aura ring oh the
whoop suddenly you know
but i mean it's not accurate but i think
the sleep is accurate
would you be able to
not sleep and just do an hour of
newcomer day
i would um there are some people
and i'm not going to name any names
there are some very high performing
nuclear reactors of energy
that think that that's an okay equation
and i am
really upset that you would even think
of that sleep is paramount if you looked
at the
necessities of life and sustainability
sleep has to be the foundation
it has to be sleep is the foundation
okay
you can't use a replacement for sleep
not because new calm isn't effective
it's because we don't know the
complexities
and the variables to sleep are so
profound
we still don't know enough about it i do
know that newcomb kind of mimics sleep
architecture but it doesn't do it
fully so i would never ever tell people
to do that
now hopefully they would get to a place
where they augment their sleep debt but
everybody
has a biorhythm interesting enough for
me i'm just
being in the space i am and kind of
perpetually inquisitive
i've noticed for me that if i sleep even
hours
i wake up and i'm ready to crush it if i
sleep odd hours i wake up and i'm
lethargic
and i got five hours last night i woke
up at five o'clock i was like
uh but i had to go to new york city so i
didn't really have time and yesterday
at six o'clock i knew calm for 40
minutes in preparation for knowing i
wasn't getting to bed before midnight
and i was only getting five hours of
sleep
i would like more sleep but as you get
older and everybody who's listening to
this podcast who's older or has kids or
whatever
once the sunlight hits your eyes man
hello so you have to sleep in a dungeon
if you want to sleep in
so sleeping in is not really an
opportunity and i find myself if i knew
calm and then i exercised or whatever
i found myself getting that second wind
at eight or nine and i like to catch up
or do whatever so
yeah five hours a night can you explain
how the
music sounds and the disc
work what's the relationship there
awesome there is none
so that's a great question um the disc
by itself
is an incredible invention and it's
incredibly complex it looks simple it
looks just like a sticker in a sesame
street comic book right
um the disc actually has a signature of
frequencies it has a recipe on it
frequencies that used to be in a cream
well
dr holloway in his inventive path and of
absolute perpetual awesomeness of
literally intellectual horsepower i
think second to none i've never met
anybody like him
he located and found the frequencies to
gaba a gaba b l
tyrosine casein typical and healthy
innate
those are the elements kind of this
cornucopia what's called an inhibitory
neurotransmitter
puts the brakes on stress he took the
frequencies
and built a software that disc
is has a nice design and it looks cool
and it's circular and it's metallic
it's actually a six layer multi-wave
oscillator holds a biostatic charge
invented by george acosta the russian
medicine
doctor doing electro medicine in the
1930s
technologically it's been around for 100
years it still isn't understood and
still
deployed well so the signature of
frequencies
is then imprinted in a tesla coil onto
that disc and that disc is held in a
faraday bag the faraday bag is a physics
bag anti-static bag
the disc is really powerful but taken
into the environment
it's very vulnerable to emfs so the disc
is simply signaling your brain like a
tuning fork to activate what's called
the gabinergic system
and the disc is important because it's
like having a glass of wine or two
it negates your ability to resist new
calm
because of your adrenaline it shuts down
your adrenal cortex
so literally this disc uses the body's
natural amino acids
in a very unique very advanced form
to simply turn on the gabinergic system
and say hey we're going to take you for
a joyride into theta
and you're not going to resist we're
about to do so that's what the disc does
that's the chemical messaging of new
calm
then the eye mass simply negates visual
stimulation then
most of the work 75 percent maybe 80
sometimes 60 percent
is in the neural acoustic software
underneath music you're going to hear
beautifully architected music the music
is really avant-garde and kind of
you've never heard it before because we
use the sulfate geo-ancient music scale
and we build this stuff in 528 hertz or
432 hertz really complex
geometry fine but underneath it
is six million dollars of the most
sophisticated patented
software ever created huh
what do you mean a typical song is about
five megabytes
newcomb rescue 70 is 1.49
gigabytes when you download the track
it's 1.5 gigabytes of mathematics
we're using to trick the most
sophisticated
organ in the history of the planet your
brain and what we're doing
is we're using all this complex physics
and math to simply pace your brain like
a nascar pace car
we take you to 12 hertz and then we
cycle you in this
kind of space of 12 hertz to 4 hertz
mostly in theta
so the experience is really unique and
fun because you're just listening to
music you can't hear it's inaudible to
the human ear but we're pacing you into
12 hertz
ignite on the other hand the ignite
warrior brain
we raise the decibels of the physics so
that you can feel that thundering pulse
low end it's like that's the physics
that's all the math and all the stuff we
wanted we put that in there because
we've been working with special forces
in the us military we've been working
with professional athletes
we didn't want them to think they were
listening to just music we wanted to
understand
there's six million dollars of patented
physics underneath this music
driving your brainwave function up to 39
40 and 41 hertz
when you're telling me that there was
special ops soldiers
sat in the choppers on the way out to do
operations and they've all got it on
as they're flying out yes that's the
the coolest advert for a product that i
can imagine
it's some call of duty [ __ ] it is call
of duty [ __ ] and it's pretty amazing
because when you are in mistake free
high intense focus that's where you need
to be for a mission
and for me i'm a lay person i'm a
civilian i've never been in the military
it seems stressful to me to go on a
mission but it's not
that's where all their training lies the
stress to a military operative is their
home life
or their spouse or their kids or paying
the bills whatever it's it's
odd to me so we do a lot of work in the
military i'm really uh
pleased and impressed by their
capability their sacrifice what they do
and at first when we first started
working with them i felt almost an
ethical battle i was like
i'm relaxing warrior so you can kill
people better and i thought to myself no
that's not the way to look at it i'm
taking care of soldiers who are
sacrificing their life for
the protection liberties and freedom of
us and furthermore
they're 18 to 35 years old and they're
giving modafinil and uppers to get into
their mission or give an ambien when
they get back from their mission
no i'm going to solve that problem so
yeah we do a lot of work with the
military mostly special forces do a lot
of work with the fbi
and then we do a lot of work with
probably three or four hundred of the
world's top athletes
and so they have their own recipe yeah
have you done any
clinical studies into the effects of
warrior brain yet
yeah well we always look at dopamine for
that and really just a brainwave
function so we'll look at an eeg to make
sure
that when we say your brain at 12
minutes is at 39 hertz that's what we're
looking at
we've never done any output stuff and we
won't do a lot of work like that
we're doing research right now with the
united states air force special
operations command on fatigue pilot
fatigue and surgeon fatigue
that's pretty cool because you know
fatigue creates errors
and errors create death all right fine
we're also doing work in psychiatric
world
around ptsd comorbid addiction and the
ability of new calm to resolve
the autonomic nervous system stress
response and allow you to heal
and we're also doing research with the
former medical director anavel on
concussions
busy busy one way to put it
oh it's awesome man it's a it's an
awesome place to be
it's an awesome it's awesome to wake up
every day knowing you're
solving people's problems changing
people's lives the amount of
of goodwill and the amount of great
stories we get
when you liberate a human from stress
you change their life
period and when you do that for a
dad or a mom and you take care of their
children
it's incredible and what's cool about
nuke home is
i don't have to be there it's a
technology
tony robbins is a dear friend and i love
tony and the mission he's on and the
purpose he's on is amazing and admirable
and he's exceptionally gifted
but he's one to many new call
is one to seven point six billion people
we just have to get in your hands
we need to create awareness education
understanding
you know i look at the sleep industry
like i said earlier it's 585 billion
dollars
who thinks that buying a bed is going to
improve my sleep
that's how little you understand about
sleep it's not an external issue
sleep is not external changing my sheets
and changing my bed
is not going to help with the
nutritional deficiency
the nutrients the physiology the
cortisol
the melatonin the l-theanine the gaba in
my brain
so we know so little about sleep that
there's people
out there selling garbage to people that
is not a solution
that's a problem we need to solve that
problem
what are you doing next what you're
working on next you've got warrior brain
to get people jacked up
you've mentioned the focus thing but
i've not seen that on the app is that
not released yet
you're not going to see it and probably
till the first quarter of next year
that's precisely why here's what you're
going to see next
and this is crazy exciting to me
we have an isochronic waveform so what's
what's speak english jim
i will so when we work on new coleman
ignite
you have to use headphones there's
binaural signal processing we're using
some physics and some trickery and some
compensation of the brain
to present it with a pattern you need
headphones
isochronic waveform is a physics
platform and a waveform
that can pace your brain without
headphones
so it's not as powerful like if i listen
to ignite through my computer
i get jacked if i listen to it with
headphones i want to freaking tear the
face off my grandma right
so the headphones create a greater
experience
we built a sleep track that accelerates
you into delta
0.5 hertz isochronically
so there's no headphone you just put it
you know you have an ipad or whatever
you have in your bedroom
and you play the track it's 50 minutes
you play one time through
you ain't staying awake it's incredible
so i know intuitively within a year
the sleep side of what we do and what we
deliver to humans will be the number one
thing our business is built around
we came to the world with new calm with
a specific intent of liberating people
from stress but
as we've evolved as we've learned and as
we've seen life as we know it
sleep is the biggest issue now we know
and the neuroscience and physiology side
stresses normal catalyst to poor sleep
but let's just go right to the problem
so i think the sleep neuroacoustic
software
is going to change the world and i think
it's going to change the landscape
you can't stay awake so in the event
that you have onset of sleep problems
mostly that's gaba deficiency and
neurotransmitter imbalance
you're going to listen to this it's
going to put you out in the event that
you wake up at three in the morning
because your liver has to create
adrenaline to enzymatically break down
your toxins your liver has a biorhythm
people are like i walk about two or
three and i don't know why
uh hey [ __ ] your liver has a
biorhythm
it's called it wakes up and does its job
between two and three so it's not
coincidence you wake up
every night of two to three that's the
body's biorhythm
but when you do and you sit there and
you persevere on things you can't solve
at three o'clock in the morning
you put the track on again bye bye
good night so that's coming next and
that's coming in the fall
we're gonna have three master tracks
each track takes months and months to
create
so people don't understand the
complexity and i don't want them to
this isn't about the complexity of
neuroscience i don't care and nor do i
want to know how a microwave works i
just know it heats up my food
i don't want people to care or know how
new calm works it's far more complicated
than microwaves
i just want you to know it's going to
put you in control of your life
your emotional stability give you energy
clarity and liberate you from stress and
allow you to be the best you you can be
that's what i want people to know but in
the event that people are curious
the neuroacoustic software takes months
to build a single track because
it's not music just based on masking
it's music based on every second of
every minute
has to go in congruence with the physics
and the math
there's a mathematical matrix that our
composers have to follow it's literally
like brain surgery
so when we launch sleep we're working on
it now we're going to have three master
tracks all of them will be 50 minutes
five zero
you listen to it once one will be like
pink noise and brown noise combined
one will be environmental sounds like
new calm and then one will be
um melodic sounds like new call so
that's sleep that's coming next so what
we're doing right now
chris is really fun we have created a
business and a brand new call
and we have a lot of people that use it
great we've
simplified it we've dropped the price 99
and we're welcoming thousands of people
a month
that's great we have ignite we've teased
it twice
people are starting to adopt it and
starting to understand it no one knew
that we even had it besides people that
signed a confidential agreement with the
us military and professional athletes
we have that out there sleep is coming
but what we're doing right now is we're
going to go
back to the well and work with our
creative agency to create an umbrella
brand
and that brand is going to be the
portfolio of what we do because what we
do is not new call and it's not ignite
and it's not sleep and it's not
focused what we do is allow you as a
human being to dictate
what state change you want and for you
to manage your state using our
clinically proven
patented physics in mathematics in
biochemistry
and electrical signaling on demand
so to do that we need an umbrella brand
i like the concept of tuning
i've always liked the tuning blake used
to say hey this is
it's like we're like fine-tuning a
musical instrument that's what newcomb's
doing
i like the idea of tuning up tuning in
tuning out
i don't know if that's gonna resonate
and how we're gonna do this but we're
gonna have an umbrella brand
and then under that umbrella brand we're
gonna have new calm
ignite focus and sleep those are the
four elements
to the whole range of 41 hertz to 0.5
hertz the whole
human experience we own at your
fingertips
and then we built the voice and speech
recognition in the
new calm stress and fatigue assessment
tool that we deployed with the fbi the
fbi uses that every day
to show readiness of their operators for
their missions
so it's able to verbally detect the
pattern it's a criminal
voice and then give them a readout of
how stressed they are
yeah it's patterns it's cadence it's
word choice it's amazing so
you speak extemporaneously that you see
a picture you speak into your phone for
20 seconds
it captures 10 million data points and
uses regressive analysis to spit out
your stress response now in the moment
it's wild man
that to me is like okay quantitatively i
want to see
the impact newcomb's having so yeah so
that's what we're doing so this summer
is going to be a blast because we get to
kind of
build the spaceship and say hey guess
what we're coming in september with a
whole new look and feel
and a whole new offering that includes
new calm
ignite and sleep this is proper tony
stark stuff man
it really is um what's fascinating for
me
is that we're we play kind of in left
brain allopathic medicine we also play
in eastern medicine we also play in
physics and things that are not
understood we play in resonance and
vibration
and frequency and there's some really
fascinating stuff but it's
for us it's all built around wanting to
help and want to serve
and so it feels really good um
thankfully i was raised with good
parents there's no nefarious
genes in my dna because we can do some
really
weird stuff if we wanted to we can
implant words in your midbrain we can do
through the software yeah
we can do a lot of uh interesting stuff
for good and for bad and so we choose
good
and we choose to do really cool things
that's sick man jim pool ladies and
gentlemen everyone that's
listening that thinks i want a bit of
this where should they go
new call n-u-c-a
dot com and you can get started and join
the family there
and from there you can then uh learn
about
ignite and there's several different
ways to get started there's a monthly
subscription there's an annual
subscription there's a lifetime
subscription
most people you know we're domestic us
company we do sell around the globe
most people who buy internationally buy
the annual
just because shipping expenses are silly
but yeah come join the family and come
take a technology that's been around for
20 years
and that will liberate you and become
your best friend no judgment
no shame no guilt just hey it's time for
me to go new calm go in your bed
get on a good recovery get up feeling
amazing and go take on your day
i love it man thanks so much for today
pleasure take care of yourselves kovit's
over
now we're the calm after the storm let's
go
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace
you